hello everybody welcome to this video
which is not a podcast in light of
current events we figured I was just
really not the time to podcast a normal
podcast where we have light-hearted
games discussions hangouts all with
sponsors that we monetize and instead of
doing so we wanted to get on here and
record a short little video just telling
you guys that we are we are supporting I
am supporting we were supporting the
black lives matter movement we are proud
of people out there using their voice
and protesting and this is a big moment
in our history and it's a moment of
change and it's a moment of movement is
a big movement happening right now and
in light of all that we do we just felt
like we couldn't you know do our normal
podcast so here we are yeah I mean I
will say that we were speaking as people
like outlet there's no script or we did
not try and plan anything to say so if
we say anything that's not 100% perfect
just know that it's coming straight from
our heads and our hearts and we do try
our best to stay somewhat out of
politics and but this to me is not a
political issue this is a human rights
issue and this is a systemic oppression
brutality against african-americans in
our country and there have been riots
for years there has been demand for
change for years and we have truly
reached a boiling point and for us to I
think Julien and I have sat here through
many years of we said we have a
conversation about what feels
appropriate depending on what's going on
in the world and sometimes we sit and
have a discussion about it because I
think that's what people in our audience
will
like and maybe some of you would want
that right now but to sit here in you
know sort of read a sponsor and have a
normal podcast just feels a little
inappropriate at the moment and we want
to act on that rather than anything else
I but it's yeah it's a lot yeah yeah and
we're aware of our privilege and we're
you know completely trying to use any
sort of you know moments that we have
your guys attention to let you know that
this should not be ignored and I do just
want to reiterate there's a lot of you
guys I've seen a lot of you guys I do
follow a lot of you and you're
protesting and you're out there and
you're using your voice and you you're
making me proud and I want you to know
whether you're out in the streets
protesting or you're using your voice
online or you're talking to your friends
and family that this is truly a it's a
tipping point in our country and you or
you are either you know you're either on
the side of human rights and on the side
of black people who have been constantly
oppressed and mistreated by a systemic
faulty government for years and years
and years and years and years tons and
tons of times over and over Ori or
you're on the wrong side of history and
I want you to know that we appreciate
you guys using your voice and we're
trying within what we can do what we
have the ability to do to to be vocal as
well and to support as well we you know
we as you know we stream on Twitch and
the last handful of streams we've done
and actually to be honest the next
foreseeable future of all the streams
we're going to do will be
in efforts to raise money for
organizations supporting black lives
matter and supporting in the protest and
supporting the people of this country
who deserve the support and need the
support and have been without the
support for far too long so if you do
want to hang out with us so to speak
online that is a twitch is a good place
right now for for that because we're
going to be continuing our charity
efforts there and yeah I mean I don't we
just wanted to get on here and and kind
of have a heart-to-heart with you and
just kind of talk about what's going on
for a quick moment and explain why it's
not a regular podcast and why we're not
playing heads up seven up with you know
our sponsors and you know we are not
sorry we're not sorry for the lack of
content we're not sorry to our sponsors
for having a you know cancel this
episode obviously this video won't be
monetized we will include links in the
description for many different ways that
you can support what's going on in
addition we will will link the bailout
funds for people who are being arrested
in the protest where you can support
their because that is a huge help as
especially right now with all the cities
across our country in protest yeah I
mean you you have to understand just if
maybe you know you're not in the United
States and some of it feels a little not
close to home to you imagine how fed up
people have to be in order during a
global pandemic to gather in the sizes
that they have to do protests the police
brutality in this country against black
people is literally like people do not
care the plague is going to our people
are in the streets so sick and tired and
it's just it should have never happened
and we will not stand for it ever
happening ever again
and that's how tired we are of this in
our country and it's just a month ago
you know people are in there
and panicked about getting sick and now
we're seeing protests all over the
country in just massive quantities
that's how tired we are this yeah also
I'm not any sort of expert on I don't
think anyone really is but on protests
and on precautions you can take but I do
know that it is important to both if
you're out in protest travel in groups
have a buddy have a backup method of
communication they're shutting down cell
service their signal jamming and also
wear face coverings not only for the
virus but for identification purposes
you don't want to be able to be easily
identified obviously again I've I've not
been out there yet and I don't claim to
know everything but I just want you guys
if you are going out there if you are
choosing to protest out on the streets
just try to take as many precautions as
you can because we don't want any of you
guys to I don't want people to get sick
I don't want people to get hurt I care
the majority of the people around you
care about you and it's just it's a hard
time right now
for everybody everyone is hurting
everyone is sad everyone is fed up and
sick and tired and this is just an
expression of our collective hurt and
that change has to happen yeah it has to
happen and it's coming to a point right
now where everyone has had it and people
have had it and it's it's very clear
with what's going on in the streets that
people are just they don't give a [ __ ]
and they shouldn't give a [ __ ] because
this is this is the moment where
movement needs to really start happening
and really needs to affect change yeah
that's why we are not podcasting this is
just a you know I wanted to let you know
yeah um but we had a conversation all
weekend you know yeah it's it's
difficult sometimes you know when you
pre record something we don't want to
start talking about something
in a matter of days that information
changes I mean it's the same as anything
else you know by the time many of our
podcasts have been posted the
information has changed and yeah we
don't record the day it goes out just
for those who are on our way I mean we
generally record a handful of days in
advance of Monday which is what our
podcast goes live so we are currently
recording this on a Sunday honestly
we'll probably likely push this out on a
Sunday I don't see the point in waiting
you know again we'll well I think this
this should be not only on YouTube but
it should I don't think we can maybe
push this to the listening platforms as
well just so people have a word from us
if they're looking you know if people
listen to our podcast and don't watch it
again check the description if you are
looking for ways to help thank you again
to all of you for being a community that
we are proud to call our own honestly
because I've seen so many of you just
being wonderful and being humans and
supporting each other and standing up
for what's right so thank you thank you
guys and uh we hope to see you you know
for a normal podcast sometime soon but
you know only time will tell
we're in the middle of history right now
yep I've been on the internet for ten
years I mean we've seen a lot of stuff
in the world and the best thing that I
can say is that you have to just do what
feels right to you and right now
creating content that is otherwise
distracting feels wrong to me so we're
not going to do that and when it feels
like it might be an appropriate time to
do something else we'll do that but I
can't sit here and pretend like I'm not
angry and heartbroken and la-dee-da yeah
so we're just not gonna do that yeah
that's that all lives don't matter until
black lives matter you guys thank you
for listening and being here we'll see
you soon